[Music]
good afternoon everyone my name is
Dominic price
I'm the director product manager for our
storage database and capacity products
I'm Google cloud platform so I'm very
excited to be here today day three of
this amazing conference to talk about
database migration service on GCP so as
we've on-boarded more and more large
enterprise customers and we talked about
target in the keynote we've talked about
HSBC and other large companies they
often have a dilemma about how to get
their data into the cloud and so we have
a set of recommendations we give to
people when they think about these
migrations so the first thing is as
customers are moving their data into the
cloud we want to make sure that they're
realizing value all the way along so we
want to make sure that they identify
which workloads to move first get on
track get some experience get
comfortable moving at the end of the
cloud and then that allows you to
minimize the disruption to your business
so we'll take you through kind of a
framework of how we talk about that and
how we think about it and then I'll
bring up here from Illumina to talk
about how they do database migrations so
when we go in and talk to large
customers about database migration we
focus on three phases of the approach so
the first one is assessment so this is
where you actually look at the data that
you have
think about what would be most logical
to move and then we move into Phase two
which is doing the actual migration so
we'll talk about some strategies for
doing migration and the last one is
validation how do you know that your
migration was successful so phase one
assessment the first question is what
apps and databases need to move so one
of the things that's most interesting
about my job is going into customers and
then say I need to move some data to the
cloud I say great what data do you have
they're like I don't know so like okay
the first thing we need to do is go
through and actually catalog and do some
discovery on all of your databases once
we have the full list of databases we
can look at which ones might be
appropriate to move to the cloud I
this might be based on which databases
actually work well in the cloud which
ones have managed services so you're
gonna look at kind of what is the match
or mismatch of your databases to what's
available to cloud once you've
identified what some of those database
workloads are that might move to the
cloud you need to understand the
capabilities that are out there so if
you're one of the things that we see is
often a really big issue is if you're
running older versions of databases it's
often more difficult to move those to
the cloud if you have a older version of
my sequel or Postgres you might not be
able to move that into cloud sequel
because it doesn't support the same
version and so then you might not be
able to take advantage of a managed
service and you might have to actually
put that onto a GCE a Google compute
engine VM and manage that yourself so
you have to make sure that the
capabilities that are available in the
platform match with the use cases that
you have then you have to figure out
what is the right path to the cloud so
if you're moving a database or
application can that database or
application accept downtime do you have
to basically try to do a live failover
migration or can you accept an hour or
two hours of downtime can you do it over
a weekend can you do it overnight what
are the actual requirements of that
application when you want to move it
into the cloud and the last one is how
well is the target support the
application so you might want to move an
application that has a my sequel
database and that my sequel database
might be supported by cloud sequel so
you can move that database over but for
some reason that application requires
something that doesn't work well in the
pot and the public cloud maybe it only
runs at bare metal
maybe requires some api's or access to
underlying systems that make it
inappropriate to run in the public cloud
so you need to make sure that the target
of where you want to land your database
matches what you need from that
application and database so phase 2 is
the migration so what do you want to do
is as you like data once you've
identified the applications and
workloads that you want to migrate you
need to figure out what type of
migration I'm going to do so this is
actually using the Gartner set of
migration types and we've we've actually
added one because we think they we think
they forgot the most important one which
is retire so the first thing you should
do is look at all your databases and the
first thing you should say is do I still
need this database right are people
using it can it be consolidated can it
be basically retired so do I even need
to migrate that we think that's a very
important first step the second one is
replaced so another thing you need to do
is look at your database so let's say
that you're running an on-premise CRM
solution that has a my sequel database
your first question is do I want to
migrate this to the cloud or do I just
want to move to a SAS offering do I just
move to Salesforce right do I move to a
fully hosted solution like if I'm
managing if I'm moving Exchange Server
do I want to go to a hosted exchange
offering do I need to move those
databases at all or can I move to a full
SAS offering that's option number two
number three is Rijos so this is
basically moving that application and
hosting it on GCE VMs so when you move
that data over can you put it on to a
pass offering which is option number
four if I can't can I run it on a VM so
again things that end up being really
interesting here really old versions of
databases I'd less common databases so
if you have something like a marklogic
or if you're running a neo4j or
something that doesn't have a managed
offering today can you put it on a VM
and manage it yourself and so that's
option number two which is rehoused the
next one is refactor so when I talk
about our customers that are coming to
the cloud I find that they break out
into two camps there's a set of people
who have the right people in-house feel
very comfortable and want to manage
their own their own infrastructure so
they want to come and they'll actually
use our I as offerings or
infrastructures of service but what we
find is about 80 percent of people are
coming to us because they're having
trouble managing they're having trouble
hiring the people that are necessary to
manage their workloads or they're having
some other reason that they don't want
to manage infrastructure anymore so they
have a very strong incentive to try to
move to our platform as a service
offerings so cloud sequel our memory
store offering for Redis those types of
things they want to get out of the
business of managing their
infrastructure so the question is can
they move on to our platform as a
service offering so another layer up the
stack
the next one is revised so the first
three assume that you're not making any
changes to the application you're
basically picking up your application as
is running exactly the same way and
putting it in the cloud the SEC's one is
revised and modernized
so this is can you make some changes to
your application to take better
advantage of the cloud so an example is
I have an application it's currently
running on my sequel five five
that's not offered in cloud sequel can I
upgrade that application to use five six
or five seven so now I can move that on
to cloud sequel or I have an internal
application it currently uses Postgres
I'd really I'm about to go out of my
post Chris instance I'd really like to
move to cloud spanner can I actually
read platform that and rewrite that
application to work on top of our
platform as a service and the last one
is rebuild if I have an application it
might be long in the tooth it's missing
a bunch of requirements I'm just gonna
rebuild the whole application and now
you're in Greenfield and you're not
migrating anything and now you can
actually rebuild using some of our cloud
native technologies like kubernetes sto
the cloud services platform and actually
take advantage of the full power of the
cloud if you actually rewrite the
application from scratch so we are
really the the six different ways so
it's the five from Gardner plus we've
added retire which we think is a very
useful migration for people that are
moving into the cloud then you get to
the validation step and this is really
important once you've moved the data you
need to verify that that data has come
across now this might be as simple as
doing a count star console X star on all
of your tables to make sure that they're
the same number of rows and the old
databases in the new database depending
on which database technology you can do
check sums on all the data to make sure
that the data is come across but you
really need to make sure that that data
has come over holy that you want to do
is then start to optimize so you want to
look at ok those my sequel database
flags that I was using on-premise should
I be using the same flags in the cloud
probably not we probably want to use a
different set of flags to optimize for a
particular workload when running in the
public cloud we also want to do some
performance checks so obviously once you
have all the data over and you've
checked all your tuning you want to make
sure that you are having an acceptable
level of performance right you want to
make sure that something
hasn't changed with the way that you
were hosting in on-premise in the cloud
you want to make sure that your
customers are still happy with the level
of latency and performance that you're
delivering from the system so these are
the the general framework that we think
about when we talk about cloud
migrations a database migrations and so
how does Google cloud platform help so
the first thing is we define a
foundation all of our services on Google
cloud platform are industry-leading in
terms of performance whether it be our
VMs with persistent disk whether it be
cloud BigTable or cloud sequel and so we
have a strong foundation that scales
gives you industry-leading performance
and also gives you industry-leading
networking and so whenever you're doing
these migrations the thing that ends up
always being the thing that you get
stuck on is actually networking how do
you get network connectivity from
on-premise into the cloud how do you get
network connectivity from your
application into the database so all of
the tools will be provided on networking
actually our key enablers of doing
database migrations that also helps when
you can get the bytes there faster of
the network from the capabilities so we
were a number of features so we're gonna
talk about our external master feature
in cloud sequel today we also have a
number of tools that were working on and
then partners so we spent a lot of time
over the last year year and a half
building out the partner ecosystem so
working with partners like Illuma and
other partners in the space to make sure
that all of those tools that you're used
to using on-premise or in other public
clouds work great on Google cloud
platform and so you can use whatever
tool you're used to using we don't want
to force you on any particular tool we
don't want to tell you how to do your
migrations if you have a tool that
you're used to using we want to make
sure that we have a great partnership
with that partner a great relationship
with that partner to make sure that that
tool works and the last one is support
so obviously Enterprise great support we
now have two different types of
enterprise support so there's the first
which is the cost base where you get
different levels of support and then
we've gone to a role base where you can
basically pay for individual seats of
support depending on what's better for
your customer what's better for you as a
customer and what's better for your cost
structure and then lastly we offer a
number of enterprise support
mechanism so we have our professional
services organization so you spent a lot
of time talking about what the
professional services organization that
we've built at Google that can help you
with these things obviously the SRA
books are a site reliability engineering
team we published the original site
reliability engineering book and we just
published the second book which is the
workbook and then our CR es which start
customer reliability engineers this is
really interesting if you are moving a
large application if you're launching a
large application you can engage with
our customer reliability engineering
team and they will sit down with you and
talk through your launch plan your run
books how are you gonna support an
outage how are you going to deal with
the various things that could go wrong
when you do a launch so we provide all
of these services for people to be able
to take advantage of as they're
migrating their application or launching
new applications so we talked a little
bit about tooling so now we're gonna
talk about migration to cloud sequel so
one of the most common patterns we see
when people are moving relational
databases to the cloud is this model
where basically you have a my sequel
database that has managed some where
this might be on-premise it might be
another public cloud but that's where
your master is and so the easiest way to
get your data in the Google cloud
platform is to add a replica of that
database in cloud sequel so in this case
for cloud sequel for my cloud sequel for
my sequel basically you can add a cloud
sequel replica that is speaking to a
master instance a master node that is
somewhere else so this way you can
replicate all of your data into Google
cloud platform using mice equals native
replication so you get all of the
consistency guarantees and all of the
things that are possible through my
sequel via a single asynchronous
replication so you're not impacting your
performance to get your data into the
cloud once it's into the cloud you can
then add a failover replica so that you
have a chae and then you can basically
trigger a failover to then move the
application from speaking to your master
instance that is somewhere else to the
cloud sequel replicas which was a
read-only replica which is now your
master replicas and you have h a by
having a second replica where that data
is
managed so now you've moved all of your
data from another location in the Google
cloud platform
you've now replicated it so that it's
highly available and now you can repoint
your application to take advantage of
that new setup so one of the things that
we advocate always whenever we're doing
a migration of an application or
database is that we really encourage
people to take the simplest possible
approach it's very easy to boil the
ocean when you're trying to move data so
it's very importantly to try to go to
start with the simplest possible
invitation so the vast majority of
databases usually this is around 80% of
all of the databases um you can move
very simply with some down time so
basically you have an existing database
instance you basically stop writes to
that database you can allow writes reads
to continue to come in you export that
data so if it's my sequel it's a sequel
DOM it could be CSV it could be whatever
data format you basically copy that data
into Google Cloud storage and then using
cloud sequel or whichever database
you're using import that data in and
then move the database across so this is
by far the simplest way of moving data
across now this might be an hour of
downtime it might be two hours depending
on which data but if you're dealing with
100 gigabytes of data you know smaller
data sets then this is a very acceptable
way of doing this if your application
can be down overnight or over the
weekend this is by far the simplest way
to do a database migration now the the
key factor in that migration scenario
that I just gave you is how long does it
take to take that import and put it into
the new thing right so if you are
copying the data so you've done an
export of your database copying it into
Google Cloud storage because of our
network tends to be very fast and so
what the the long pole of this process
is basically how long it takes to get
your data from Google Cloud Storage into
your target database whether that be
cloud sequel or Cassandra whatever
happens to be so there here's some
general best practices that we try to
explain to people when importing
database data so the first thing is when
you import your data don't include your
indexes
so bring your data across bring the raw
data don't try to bring over all your
secondary indexes at the same time so
import your data first and then add your
secondary indexes this dramatically
lowers the amount of import time for
most databases the second thing is do
your best to import the data in primary
key order so try to make sure that your
export is ordered by primary key so that
when you're importing the data it makes
it as easy as possible for the database
to insert that data if you are using my
sequel or Postgres and my sequel
specifically it's really important that
you select a instance type that has as
much RAM as your at least your largest
table if not your entire data set by
bringing all the data in on a really
large memory instance you basically can
keep all of the data in memory and it
makes it much easier to write the data
in so you use a much larger memory size
instance initially than you might need
to run production
you can always downsize it later and so
this will really speed up the import
process and decrease the downtime that
you have in the database migration the
second thing is use our SSD storage so
persistent disk our block storage device
comes in two flavors magnetic disk and
solid-state and so if you're importing
into a GCE VM or into cloud sequel using
this option will dramatically speed up
your your input imports into the system
I don't think I remember is when you're
using a persistent disk the amount of I
apps you get on your disk are dependent
to the size of the disks so make sure
you use at least a 500 gigabyte disk to
make sure you're getting the maximum
throughput on that VM and lastly make
sure you're monitoring so you can watch
things like I ops whether this be from
your GCE VM or if this is in your cloud
sequel instance you could do this via
the cloud console or via a stat driver
and then obviously keep an eye on your
read operations because a lot of very
high read operations might indicate that
your database is paging which will
basically increase your import time so
these are all things to think about when
you're importing the data to try to
minimize the downtime when you're
migrating and then after you import
again because you're in the cloud you
haven't bought a physical device that
you can't resize you can resize your
database make it bigger or smaller you
can turn
the binary logging as necessary turning
this off ahead of time in cloud sequel
will dramatically increase your import
times and then add your indexes after
the fact
don't add indexes when you were
importing the data add them after the
fact it's much much faster it'll save
you tremendous amount of import time now
if you are doing any moving an
application that can't accept down time
you're gonna want to look at using
replication to actually move your data
across so as we talked about here you're
actually moving the data across so we're
gonna replace that step with actually
doing replication now if you're doing
like - like if you're doing my sequel to
my sequel posters - Postgres Cassandra -
Cassandra you can basically use the
native replication if you're doing
something like big my sequel - Postgres
or you're doing a heterogeneous
migration then some of the tools like a
tunity illumise some of the other
partners can help you really with that
workload because they can provide you
replication that isn't native
replication so the idea here is that
you're replicating all the data across
and then once the new instance has
caught up and you know that the lag is
sufficient so you know if this can't
ever catch up you might have to stop
rights for a small amount of time while
that replication catches up but assuming
you can get to a steady state where
there's very little lag then you
basically can move your application over
and have it speak to the other instance
and therefore you can have very low
downtime rep migrations another workload
that we talk about a lot is migrating
Cassandra to cloud BigTable or cloud
spanner for this talk we're gonna focus
on BigTable mostly because of there's
lots of cloud spanner sessions talking
about migration but what we do is one of
the most common use cases we see for
cloud Pig table is people wanting to
migrate off of their HBase or the
Cassandra clusters so we see this is a
very common use case for people moving
the cloud BigTable one of the big
questions is if I'm coming off of
Cassandra should I use cloud BigTable I
should have use cloud spanner so he put
together a little bit of information to
help you choose between the two because
Cassandra has a very wide variety of use
cases and so which you how you're using
Cassandra will determine which cloud
service you want so you want to use
cloud BigTable if you're serving derived
data if you're doing batch ingest and
analytics so if you're using it as a
true wide column store and you're trying
to write
in it and use it as an analytics cluster
then cloud big tables gonna be a better
solution for you if you're serving
user-visible and mutate able data
especially if you have multi road
transactions or you need secondary
indexes that you're gonna want to use
cloud spanner so way to think about this
is if you are using cloud if you're
losing cassandra of the local quorum to
write to a single zone cluster with
eventual consistency then cloud BigTable
is probably the right solution for you
and will give you cost advantage over
cloud spanner if you're using spanner
with each quorum or local quorums but it
it spans multiple regions in the ring
then you're gonna want to use cloud
spanner to get the same level of
functionality so how do we do this
so you have an application that's
speaking here to cassandra cluster the
most common way that we see customers
migrating and what we recommend is is
what we call a dual write structure so
basically you have an application that's
writing to some sort of queue this could
be a Kafka queue it could be RabbitMQ it
might be some place on your application
where you hold and then basically we
recommend that you do tool rights so you
have two consumers of that queue that
write the data to both cassandra and
either big table or spanner so what this
does is it allows you to basically write
data to both databases while the
application is talking to Cassandra once
you've gotten the sufficient amount of
data into the Cassandra cluster and it
is basically caught up then you can
basically look at moving it into and
switching the the path so here if you
don't want to run your own consumers you
could use cloud dataflow you can use
data proc to do this you could also use
cloud functions or some of our other
service architectures so we talked about
Kafka so some suggestions you can use
Apache Kafka if your rights are non
rights are non in them potent I always
get this word wrong this is one of the
most difficult words for me to say if
you need in order message delivering is
required or if you need compatibility
with the existing Kafka tools Scott
Kafka screamed or whatever happens to be
you can use cloud dataflow flow if your
rights are
in dem patent try that again
or out of order message deliveries okay
or need to be globally replicated so
then once you've gotten all the data
written over you've got an export to
kind of get the bulk data and then
you've dual written now you can actually
move your application to speak to cloud
BigTable and start to read and write
read the applications you're still doing
rights to both places so you can roll
back but now you can read the data from
your new database source then your
mission accomplished
your migration is done all right so with
that I would like to bring up somebody
who has much more experience than I do
with database migrations so I'll bring
up your Weinberger the CTO and
co-founder of Illuma to share some of
the tools that they provide Thank You
Dominic can you hear me my mic all right
so I'm yeah your CTO of alumina as I
mentioned and we deal with migrations
all the time and a lot of it is a to DCP
as well and I'm going to talk a little
bit more in depth about database
migration especially the more complex
use cases and the thing you can enter
but maybe for that just a little bit
about generally Illumina and data
migration so and I'm sure this is not
news to any one of you
we used to be on Prem used to have our
compute on Prem used to ever or storage
on Prem our database on Prem and what
happens now is we want to move you want
to move to modern technology we want you
to be managed as a service in the cloud
we want to use the best of breed
technologies for every one of our
workloads our applications are moving to
containers our storage is moving to the
cloud storage which is infinite and much
cheaper and and then our databases are
also moving to the cloud databases and
and this is what alumina is about so
Illumina exam and what I didn't mention
is a new applications are just born in
the cloud it's very easy you know we
create it inside the container we use
cloud sequel and it's we just let it fly
and it just working out of the box but
whenever we are looking at a little bit
a bigger company it has a lot of legacy
applications some of them the people
were the code don't exist anymore
or don't don't work for the company
some of them has you know a lot of
legacy databases petabyte of data think
one of the fan facts was however note
move over three petabytes of data only
to be moved this is a that dragon it
needs to be tamed and everyone who
experienced that knows it extremely
could be extremely difficult and
time-consuming
sometimes even takes years so just
saying I want to move to the cloud is a
can be quite difficult and now when
migrating there are three types of
migration and I'm going to focus on the
data migration part which is what the
luma is focused on as well
there is the compute instances we want
to move our computing up and workload to
the cloud our applications and services
and the data itself now because this
process is not atomic it's not like we
can start on Prem and then the day the
next day we're full in the cloud it
takes time it takes month it can takes
years while we make that move not only
we want to move the data but we want to
keep the two environments and sync
we want to make sure that whatever we
have on [ __ ] can be synced to whatever
we have in the cloud and sometimes even
back sometimes in vice versa and that's
where a luma comes in and Illuma have
built the tooling and the product as a
service in the cloud to migrate out of
the on premise data from databases from
storage from data centers or enterprise
data warehouses into the cloud and
actually all clouds but the Google in
that in that context so what is what is
how does the data pipeline no harder
than migration data pipeline look like
and this is a little bit of a peek under
the hood so you need to have a lot of
connectors connect to anything and that
could be our DBMS which is the focus of
this talk today and what I'm going to
show soon how we migrate a database
instance but that also could be files
that can exist on FTP servers on servers
on the some cloud storage that we might
have put them there that could be events
that are coming event stream who are
coming from mobile devices coming from
applications and they could even be the
SAS vendors that we use because already
not all our application are inside the
org some of
then we use Salesforce with Marketo how
about all of those new size vendors we
want to make sure we are able to read
their data as well so a lot of
connectors and then once we once we get
all of that data in we of course put it
in a message queue Illuma under the hood
uses Kafka
but that's of course not mandatory we do
believe it is currently one of the best
options in the market you want to be
able to transform or modify the data
that goes through and that's what we
call the code engine they are built to
run code on the data it goes through the
stream and we want to be able to know
how the data looks like what is the
schema so again I'm sure many of you
have used Hadoop in the past and are
familiar with a schema on raid concept
where we just push everything into that
data Lake and then take care of the
schema when we want to read the data we
believe or I believe that this is a
created a lot of problems because not
all sometimes the schema changes over
time the schema there is a skew and if
we only find out about it when you try
to read the data we might be in big
trouble already so we need to understand
and maintain the schema or how did it
look like and that can be either
imported from the source or inferred
from the data itself so if we read data
from Oracle database or anything that
have a schema with it that schema can be
imported and translated if we are
reading data from files or from event
streams sometimes the schema needs to be
inferred from the data itself and then
we need to make sure we know to put the
data wherever it belongs so I want to
show you a little bit lift a lift and
shift use case all right can I get the
other screen great so this is the low
product and what I want to show you is
how we take a database MySQL on Prem
looks like I will need my VPN here sorry
about that and take that and move it to
a my sequel cloud sequel instance in the
cloud and I actually want to add a
little bit of a twist here because as
Dominic said sometimes there are just
very simple migration where we can just
enable replication between the master
from and whatever the cloud sequel that
we have in the cloud and have led to my
sequel application take care of it
but India I want to introduce another
very common concept of charting my own
premises my sequel database is charted
and I'm writing to do different charts
but there is no need to keep the
sharding when I'm moving to cloud sequel
when I'm moving to cloud sequel of
course I can make the instance much
bigger I already have highly available
out of the box so I want to I want to
date to sharding and I want to run to
write everything to the same database
instance it makes my applications more
maintainable it makes my querying the
data more maintainable because I don't
need to query from multiple shards so
there is a little bit of a twist if I
just enable replication as is I will
keep the charting in place so what do I
do here
I have I started my cloud sequel
instance of is QL which is a which is
here and I configure it as a target for
a luma so very simple I configure that
that the same cloud sequel as a target
for a luma and then that I already did
but the only the next thing I need to do
is just to add the my sequel data source
or sources so this is again very simple
and that can be by the way that can be
Oracle that can be pretty much any any
cloud database sequel server Postgres so
I can also do lift and shift all lift
and modernize the same way in that case
if I if I take my SQL and then all I
need to provide is the connection
details the type of replication of
course change it to capture is the most
recommended one but it can be
incremental application or full dump
load replication as well and there is I
stuffed able to replicate of course I
can leave that empty and then it just
means I'm shifting my entire database I
don't want to just move a specific
subset of tables and and once I once I
got that done once that is configured I
have my data running and streaming I can
even sorry I can click on it I can see
live samples whatever comes through the
stream so in that case i I've made a
very simple use case so I have my own
Prem database I have two shards which
are in one table which is turns
actions and every every char there's
only one row in it of course in reality
it's much much bigger than that
once I set up that connection was
Tallulah will do under the hood if it
will start replicating the ongoing
changes over time and it will create a
process to dump the entire data set and
then no matter if it's one gigabyte 10
gigabyte 100 gigabyte or a terabyte that
process will happen under the hood it
will be optimized to migrate the data as
best as possible take into consideration
the other things Dominic mentioned
earlier about when to create indexes to
import by the order of primary key etc
so all of these are you're already
getting that immediately on out of the
box and then what I also set up is I've
just set up a process that continuously
updates the amount on my on my two
orders so as I mentioned we do want to
take to make sharding and to take those
two shards and put them into one table
but those charts can have conflicting
primary Heath those charts can have the
same primary key in shard 1 and chart 2
so what we do is here we leveraged the
Illuma code engine that I mentioned and
we change the data Eddie's going through
the stream and that's why we couldn't
use just simple replication and it's
really a one line module all it does is
it takes the shard from the metadata
that Illuma touched to the data and put
it in the event itself so I can actually
get live sample from the data in the
metadata I have this is like chart
number two and now I'm testing it I'm
just adding a shard ID field to the to
the data itself and that chart idea I
can I can see my I can see it was added
to the data so if I go back to to my
sequel so on tram we've seen on tram
we've seen the data just has ID created
an amount fields on the cloud sequel
part we do have the shard as well so we
have shard 1 in chart 2 and we have data
from both charts and they don't override
each other because the shard is
considered to be as part of the new
primary key on the target all right so
we got that going it's replicating
continuously it's very nice now
moving my application unfortunately
again it's not very simple to move the
application sometimes I cannot move the
application at once I need to move the
application in parts so let's say what I
did is I moved the part that only writes
to one of the charts so I'm going to
change it so right now I'm updating both
chart that's my demo application which
is updating the shards of course that is
now disconnected let's see if I can
restore it quickly this is a real life
real life demo alright so I was updating
both shards now I'm only going to update
shard number one because I migrated the
application from shower to it's already
working directly with gravity QL so it
no longer updates my own Prem database
and the only thing that's being updated
in my own pin database is chart number
one however I also want to make sure
that I'm not wrong so I want to make
sure that I didn't mess up I want to
make sure that there is nothing left in
that hodgepodge of servers that I have
on Prem that's still writing to shower
two on trim because I want to be
confident and validated I actually did a
migration successfully so what I'm going
to do is I'm going just to add another
small code engine piece in the model
that I created I'm just going to comment
that out which says ok if I'm reading
data from shard number two let's raise
an exception let's say ok I'm not
allowing any more outlets on chart
number two that will give me two things
one it will give me the visibility that
it happened but it will also stop the
data from moving because I probably
don't want that data moving now I can
also move that later but for now I want
to stop it from moving
and I'll just let's just make sure that
it's working so I got we got here a
shard number two and now when you're at
test we see that updates on Prem are no
longer expected so that's where we don't
want we don't want that data to move
anymore
so I'm going to deploy my code and now
it's still all fine because we are not
moving any data to shower two because we
change application now let's simulate
our rogue application the
one that we forgot in the data center
that is going to update shard number two
so it's going to insert what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to insert a new
transaction to the on-prem databases for
shard number two which is not supposed
to happen and then we'll see how we deal
with it so I'm going so that's what I
did and while that is populating I
actually want to show you another nice
another nice element which is a live
visualization of the data stream itself
so part of the loan product is the
ability to visualize everything that's
coming in from the data stream live so
we can see the source you can filter on
the data itself you can even see the
events themselves and this is looking
nice and also very useful for God checks
so this is now this is a more
high-volume system that actually storing
data in live I can filter on all the
events are coming from iOS from mobile
for example I can actually see those
events and this is a except being a nice
eye candy it's also very useful just for
gut-check am i getting what I'm
expecting to get is that is that data
really makes sense so going back to our
rogue application that that updated the
shard by now we have already we right
now we have already read that read that
data and and what you can see is we have
wrong data in the inner what we call the
restream queue so this is where we
handle errors we can see that what
happened you got an event that event
says char - that's not supposed to
happen we did something bad we have
still have an application we need to
find out where it is which server does
it sit on while it's writing those
events into my all own Prem database so
that's part of our validation step and I
can actually find out exactly which
application that T is what is it writing
it makes it very easy for me the fact I
actually have the sample and data itself
makes it very easy for me to find out
and once I'm satisfied with it I'm just
gonna I'm saying okay I found that
application I can just purge I can
either push that data back or you can
just purge all of this data
throw it away and saying all right now
I'm successfully migrated that chart I
can move on to migrate the other shard
as well so this was a very simple use
case of lift and shift migration of
taking data from MySQL on the source and
and again this was a we already saw a
couple of snag that you can hate while
only doing that very simple left and
shift again when you're moving your real
enterprise data set it has thousands of
tables with a terabyte of data that of
course can be much more complex and then
once you did that it's also very simple
to do lips and modernize instead of
lifted shift so I would take that MySQL
I just replaced with spanner exactly the
same way so even I move to cloud sequel
now I'm putting called sequel there in
the source and I'm putting spanner here
in the target and all of the sudden I
can tell the thousand X more transaction
volume
[Music]